Valentine's Day might be over but love
is still in the air for amanda bynes the
actress posted this photo of herself
with her quote lover a day after she
shocked the internet with a massive
engagement ring amanda showed off her
dark hair and heart-shaped face tat
while standing in front of a man who is
all smiles even though she didn't tag
him did the former Nickelodeon star just
make this Instagram official oh well
we're not sure if this is Amanda's
mystery man but if he is we're giving
him props for that gorgeous diamond ring
just a day before she posted the
sparkler and captioned it engaged to the
love of my life
fans couldn't help but wonder if she was
already married her mystery man was also
wearing a gold wedding band but little
by little the 33 year old has been
sharing an inside look at her life since
checking out of a sober living facility
in December the actress also got candid
in a 20-18 interview with paper magazine
about her struggles with mental health
drug use and body image which ultimately
resulted in a public breakdown but
Amanda said quote I have no fear of the
future I've been through the worst and
came out the other end and survived it
so I just feel like it's only up from
here
[Music]